my name is brandon benve
i work at mozilla on the firefox
devtools
and i'm going to talk about continuum
which is not this i've just noticed
there's a i didn't sponsor this
conference so that's not me
continuum is a javascript virtual
machine
and it's written in javascript
it parses javascript code into asked
compiles the ask to bytecode and
interprets the bytecode in a runtime
environment
it also has a debugger api and it has a
web interface
for you know playing around with it and
that's what you see there
so first i'm just going to crash course
on
ecmascript versions um because
we can talk about javascript in general
whenever you know it's not specific to a
version but
there's it's important to know just the
basic differences here
so es3 came out in 1999
um it started i think ie 5.2 was the
earliest and
you know whatever browsers were out back
then netscape
something five six i don't remember um
and that also is the main version of uh
ecmascript up to i8 which some people
are still
building for now so that's actually
important the difference between es3
oops ah skip the thing
so es5 came out 10 years later es4
didn't go anywhere so that died
um
so that is the first version of ie to
have that is i9 it's in modern engines
the biggest
changes with it um as access or
properties
property attributes in strict mode
and then es6 is still in the works um
spec changes every every every month or
every two months there's a new spec
out so it's still moving fast big
changes
and that are module system proxy
uh collections iterators generators
there's a lot more but those are just
the
the sort of you know high notes
and that's currently being implemented
in spider monkey and
v8 behind flags spider monkey actually
started implementing a lot of these
things
long ago and a lot of the
implementations that are in spider
monkey are not actually compatible with
us in the spec
so there's this kind of weird thing
where you have this
stuff where it's like backwards or it
won't be compatible so they have to
support both
but they're updating quickly
so why would i do this why would i do
create javascript engine in javascript
it seems like crazy thing to do why
would you do that
i actually have some pretty good reasons
first of all experimentation with new
features
we can add new features to existing
engines but
it's hard they're mostly they're they're
implementing the c plus plus
they are performance oriented so they
there's a lot of stuff in them that
isn't you know it's not about the
specification it's about
it's not about the features even it's
just about making javascript fast and if
you just want to play with new features
and test them out
give feedback on an evolving spec
it's it's not the route that you want to
go
it takes so much effort to implement a
new feature in
an existing high performance engine then
it's like if it's not
nailed down then people don't want the
implementers don't want to add it
and even when you if you do that if
you're just adding it to one engine so
if the goal is to
for regular javascript developers to
give feedback on the feature to say
oh this is good or we need to tweak this
they you're only going to
be able to look at it in that one engine
so you're sort of limiting yourself
and the as the draft is the spec is
still
a draft so it's constantly changing like
i just read on twitter
minutes ago that apparently promises are
gonna be an es6 and that was not
something that
was even like yesterday i wouldn't have
guessed that so
things are changing so fast and even
iterating and changing
like as the something like for example
generators
they've already completely changed so in
the time that the es6 spec has been
from when it was first created until now
so the
and you can't really implement it in the
engine without
[Music]
being afraid of losing all that work or
having to change and having
incompatible implementations
and for personally i wanted to learn the
language like
a lot i wanted to learn it in depth um
javascript on the surface is a
deceptively simple language it looks
uh simple but it's not it's really easy
to approach
um from a beginner's standpoint somebody
who doesn't even isn't
you know familiar with programming or
isn't familiar with javascript
specifically it's really simple to get
started
and to make stuff that works but when
you get to that intermediate level and
you're trying to make bigger programs
or you're trying to do more complicated
things you start to run into like the
the rough edges and the the
inconsistencies and also this
there's the depth of what's there and
it's not obvious on the surface i think
that's a credit to javascript
that it seems so simple because it's
able to hide the complexity
underneath so
i decided that implementing the spec is
probably the if i wanted to really get
familiar with
every single thing about it then
implementing the spec is i mean you have
to
you have to look at every single step of
every single thing in the spec and
understand it to do that
so it was a sort of a journey for me to
learn how to learn all the
hundreds of i think the es6 spec is
now up to almost 500 pages and it was
certainly a journey
going through all those pages
another thing is people talk about
transpilation or source of source
compilation
some things can be converted pretty
simply for example here we have the
arrow functions in es6 which
you know they translate to es5 pretty
simply where you have the
lexical this binding which you can you
can sort of fake using bind
and then the automatic return of the the
body
just adding return but that doesn't
translate if you do some more complex
things like
if you're trying to translate from es5
to es3
accessors there's no way to do that like
with it's just a source trans
translation you would have to
convert every single property access
into a function call and it would
you would have to actually implement
implement a runtime that would check if
there was a function
but basically you would have to do what
i did which is built the javascript
engine to do that
so the same thing happens when you look
at es6 proxies
which you can overload and get callbacks
for every single
of every single action against an object
get set
get home proper games everything there's
no way that you can implement that
without some sort of run time some sort
of
extreme transformation of the code or
an actual full blown engine
and final reason was to explore new ways
of debugging
and visualization so when i first
created this i didn't
i wanted to like look at things that
were
sort of below the surface of the engines
they don't expose things to you
they don't you can't look at what the
scope of a function is
like from from javascript itself you
can't access that information it's not
there for you
and the developer tools for each engine
are able to get around that by sort of
engine specific uh
apis that provide that information to um
to people to to to secure accesses like
um basically like chrome code um
it's it's not it's it's not available to
just anybody who wants to go along and
make a debugger
you have to have a special access
special priority
so with this this exposes it to since
the engine is in javascript you have
access to everything i can look at the
environments
um you can see you can see what the code
that's been executed you can look at
everything you have access to everything
and that's that was sort of the big
thing for me was being able to look at
these things
and also i guess i could have done this
with any and
with other stuff but i just like to like
colors a lot so
i really enjoyed making a thing that was
super colorful
so next thing life cycle of a line of js
from
source to execution go through the
different steps
first part is parsing i use esprima
which is a parser implemented in
javascript
uh i didn't make it but it's it's really
awesome and i use it there's a harmony
branch
which is es6 it's still in progress but
obviously it was good enough to
implement most of this most of the
features that were in es6 already and i
contributed some stuff back that
to help with that so with this you turn
a line of javascript or any javascript
code into
a asked it's represented as json here
it's so you can serialize this simply
enough um
and this is the basically the tree of
you know
the syntax tree of everything that's in
there and this is enough information to
to execute this is actually the
beginning of the inspiration of when i
i was playing around with the source
transformation and esperma like the
ast i was like you know i could totally
make a thing to execute this i bet it
wouldn't be too hard look
i could see all the different things and
it was like way harder than i expected
but
but it was still kind of like an
inspiration because you can sort of see
when you see there's like oh man it's
all the pieces that's everything in
javascript it's sort of broken down it
looks
so simple and clear
so the next step is to compile compile
the byte code
walks the ast produces byte code
stack machine byte code so there's
there's a stack machine and register
machine stack machines more is simple
simpler to implement and so i chose that
route
and uh you have to do a register
allocation or any
anything like that and also while
walking the ask to produce bytecode also
uh implements a
static semantics which in this in the
spec every uh
every production every syntax production
is broken down to
static semantics and runtime semantics
static semantics are things that
you don't need to know anything about
the actual you know you don't need to be
running the code to look at and make
decisions about it like for example
you can't use let but you can't use the
same name for letting cost twice in the
same scope
so you can determine that up front you
don't need to execute the code to see if
it's there twice you just have to look
at it
so there's every single every single
production has this like list of things
that you need to check
like early errors uh syntax errors but
also things like
figuring out what all the bound names of
a function are all the all the uh
variable all the functions and all the
names and stuff so that's that's done up
front um
at the same time instead of instead of
walking the ass
multiple times which probably about 30
to 40 percent of the execution time of
this
is walking the ass and producing the
bike cover but mostly walking the ast
so it does it all in one pass if you do
it multiple passes it actually
increases the time greatly so you need
to try to do everything at the same
exact time so here i have two example um
uh ask node handlers basically so we got
a binary expression
and every every one of these just gets
the node the actual node so all of them
have the same
the same argument here so
you go through the different if the
recursing just basically bounces off
finds what the type of that node is
and then recurses down and keeps going
calling all the appropriate uh
handlers and you can see the capital
letters here that's
that's the the bytecode emitter so this
is emitting a byte a get
byte code so you can see everywhere
there's every time there's the capital
letters and stuff there's
there's this is recording you know at
the current
the current code object is recording a
new
byte code and also some of the byte
codes have um
the operands for the bytecode you can
see like j true jump of true
start and a start is actually the the um
so you can see it records the current uh
instruction position
so you know this so you can see the do
while loop it'll jump
from the end if true back to the start
so you can see this is it's it's very
it's very difficult to program like this
stuff it's unstructured programming
you're jumping around you shouldn't you
can't you're not supposed to use a
go-to but you have to when you're doing
this kind of stuff this is
and there's a lot of it's there's a lot
of subtle bugs that come up where you
can just go up an infinite loop and you
have no idea why because you just
jump to the wrong place or something
that was the thing that i had issues
with when
converting all of these things to to
emit byte code
and you can see the loop here the reason
it does that is because you have to sort
you have to um
if there's any break or continues inside
of the loop you have to jump to the
right place but you can only know where
to jump
after you've gotten to the end so this
goes and fix up fixes up all the uh
the offsets construction positions
next step is to interpret the bytecode
so each op code that was emitted there
has a corresponding function that will
do
what needs to be done for that opcode
and it calls into the run time as needed
like not everything goes into the
bytecode some stuff needs to be done
during run time and also there's so you
can
there's a lot of things in the run time
that could be in the byte code but it's
instead of writing them as byte code and
with the unstructured programming
it's actually implemented in the runtime
um
to make it easier to understand now if i
was trying to optimize this i would move
as much stuff into
bytecode emitter and then try to
optimize the bytecode but since this
isn't really about
optimizations it's just it's about
clarity i'd move some more things to the
runtime than normally would be needed
and there's a few specialized slots for
error return values they don't just go
up the stack
so here we have the binary the uh
executes the binary op code so we given
a context
which has all the information that we
need so we get the instruction
the ip is the instruction position sp is
the stack position
so we get the instruction if we need
operands we get that from the
instruction
um so for like a binary operation we
need to know what
which operation it is and then we grab
the right opera uh the right
the right value and the left value and
then we pass it off to the runtime
binary operation runtime which
it'll convert if like left and right
need to be converted to
um strings or whatever that's that
happens in the run time that happens in
the
binary operation there the result now we
don't i don't
there when you throw an error there's no
actual try like i'm not try catching in
my code
i'm the return value if it it's a it's
an abrupt
completion that means there was an error
and it'll have that property so i can
just check for that and if the
if it's a abrupt completion then we pass
off the result to the context we put on
the error slot
and then we return the next function to
execute it's just
going in a loop executing whatever the
function returns so here
if it's an error we return unwind which
unwinder will
figure out where we need to go how many
um
how much needs to be popped off before
we can or if it's not caught then we
just go it gets thrown out to the outs
of the
everything stops finally we put the
result
back on the stack and return the next
function to call
so meanwhile we're going to the runtime
a lot most of the
most of the up the op codes
call out to the runtime because they
need to do stuff they need things to
happen and it can't happen
in if it's if it didn't happen in the
bytecode it wasn't encoded in the
bytecode that needs to be
going the runtime the runtime implements
the meta object protocol
this is like object dot get object out
whatever
um it manipulates objects and
environments sets properties
sets uh variables sets
all that stuff manages the execution
context
which is what has all the information
about where we're at where we're
executing
um what's the next instruction that's
that's managed by the run time so an
execution context
is um you push and pop so it's a stack
so when you have an existing execution
context you push a new one on like if
you call a function
then that one points to it's actually a
linked list
so it points to the outer
context so when that function finishes
it goes back to the outer execution
context
the runtime interpreter callback call
each other so
like um when you call a function
from the from the bytecode that
function goes into the runtime sets up
the function and then it goes back into
executing the bytecode for that new
function
so we're going back and forth between
the runtime and the
uh the interpreter
so the object representation is
how do we represent these objects the
javascript objects we i mean we have a
host engine that has objects
and we want objects in our vm what's the
relationship
so there's an uh an old older uh
javascript and javascript engine
called narcissus which is made by
brandon eikin's people in mozilla
which is labeled as the meta circular
interpreter
because it puts like a very thin layer
over existing objects like one
object in the vm in narcissus is
equivalent to the
one object in in the host engine and
there's not really much
polish on top it's a very thin layer it
uses reuses most of the host engine
functionality without
without putting too much on top which
can be efficient but that requires
that your host engine implements this
stuff if you want to implement
property descriptors or accessors in es3
then you can't do that you can't
rely on the host engine to get that
information
so continuum
is somewhat meta-circular like it
it reuses for example regular
expressions it just wraps them and
it doesn't do any of that stuff it
doesn't implement that and one
object in the vm is represented by at
least one host engine object but
usually more and there's not a direct
there's a translation layer between
getting a property for example in an
object in the vm
it turns into function calls and stuff
in the in the actual
host engine
so here is the object this is the based
object type representation
so here you can see all these all these
upward case
names these are actual spec the spec
meta object protocol so you can see
when you create a new object you set a
prototype it doesn't reuse you're not
using the host engine's prototype
chain you're creating your own prototype
chain so
you can do whatever you can you can
create stuff however you want
and it actually stores properties in its
own representation since we can't we
can't reuse property
we don't have property descriptor
information in es3 then we need to
create our own
representation so property list here
will keep that information
at the the host engine level and
accessors and all that stuff
so when you want to interact with one of
these objects you see if you want to get
a property from you can't just
you know do dot access like it's a
regular object you have to do dot get
the key or you know dot whatever get
home property
which will return a descriptor
and this is pretty much a one one ratio
for the actual spec
if you look at like um like a
v8 or spider monkey you won't see
exactly this one one one to one
relationship between the spec and what
they've implemented they've
done things that um either their legacy
or they just
it it implements the semantics from your
code
from the code code's point of view but
it doesn't
it doesn't actually use these same
things
since i was following the spec and i
wasn't trying to optimize or anything
like that
i was a i followed the spec exactly
although the spec has changed so it's
hard to keep up sometimes because
they've been
they've been doing a lot of changes with
it um
so if you want to manipulate a vm object
from outside of the vm you have to do
go through hoops basically
for every interpreted piece of code
there's an equivalent much more verbose
way to do the same thing
outside the vm and this is the same
thing in a
other other javascript engines um if you
look at like the v8 api it's like super
verbose i mean you're in c
plus plus so it's already over rows to
begin with but you have to do this
extra explicit what you're you know what
you're doing so the code at the top is
what you would execute inside the
javascript
vm and that then the code at the bottom
you can see that you're actually
creating a new object is like you have
to
specify which prototype it is and you
have to create the new object and then
if you want to set a property you have
to
call the meta object protocol for adding
that stuff
and also since i'm assigning here to
just i'm not doing a variable
declaration or whatever it's assigned to
the global object
um and a realm is basically it's a set
of it's a it's it's a
global object so it represents the
global objects and all the intrinsics
so associated with it all the default
stuff like object function and lots of
other things like that
so the function representation is a
subclass of object
but adds call and construct
obviously we need those
a function also has code which is
represents the byte code also the static
information
that we've extracted like bound names
and that kind of stuff
and also has a scope which is the
environment record um
this is a linked list you'll have outer
outer outer until you reach the global
scope so when you create a function
object to represent something it has a
scope that doesn't ever change
it's set when you first create it
this is a basically a sort of cliff
notes of what the actual implementation
looks like
um you create a function
you gotta you know set the prototype and
set the initialize and stuff this code
in the scope
in the call and construct functions you
you get
an argument list which i use in a right
to represent it and the receiver is the
this arg
um you know if there's like a method
call it'll be the object or it'll be
like undefined if you just call a
function
directly manipulating functions
is also verbose so at the top we're
creating a foo
object with an add method on it and
calling it
outside the vm you have to create
actually a screw up there should be new
function
um
i know that's correct sorry i create a
new foo
object which i'm using dollar signs here
to sort of represent the
objects that are that are vm objects
because you have to interact with them
so differently that it's important to
sort of differ differentiate what what
you have
um and so i cheat here since like i
don't want to
manually create all the byte code for
this function i can't i don't
you know that would be ridiculous so i'm
sort of cheating here and just using
evaluate and this will return
a function an arrow function and then i
set that as add and then i call it
refer you have to get the function and
you have to call it on the receiver
now recently inspect they added invoke
which you could do with add one step but
i haven't implemented that you can see
here i'm passing an array of the
arguments
a native function is something i added
to wrap functions that are in the out in
the
engine and they're not implement there's
no they don't have code they weren't
interpreted
and they they don't they're not run in
the interpreter they're just outer
functions
that are in the base engine the the
host engine so the cheat here is all you
need to do is
set the call property of the of a
wrapper function to be the function
so whenever that function is called by
some code in the
interpreter it'll call dot call and pass
in the receiver in the arguments
so it's pretty it's pretty simple to do
so an example of doing this
is so here again we create the foo
object this time we created add
native function and here we're just
passing a regular javascript function
you see a receiver in args and then
you have to you know manually spread out
the arguments and the names or if you
want to
to sort of label them so this will have
the same result and then you evaluate
you can call it
you can see here we're calling it inside
of the virtual machine
food.ad 510 and it works
standard library implementation so
javascript has a pretty extensive
standard library um
i think maybe like half the spec or so
is the standard library this is all the
stuff that you see array object
date all that stuff is the javascript
standard library
and in continuum it's implemented in es6
probably about a third of continuum's
code is written in es6 and
it's run every time you create a new
realm
you know glue new global object and so
there's this sort of initialization time
where it's kind of turned through
ten thousand lines of code and it builds
all these objects
all these interfaces the prototypes and
their classes
and this is not all of this all the
built-ins but it's a lot of them
the screenshot so
exposing primitives to library code
because primitives is something that's
implemented in the host engine that's
implemented in es3 basically es6 code
calling into the es3 code
so here is an example of exposing
a bound function create which is in the
spec
um primitive to the
internals module so it's just you can
see here a receiver args and it's you
know spreading out to naming them and
then it returns a new bound function
bound function is just a function that
it's the same as a function but you set
you know you set the properties of the
target and stuff so it knows how to call
the
with the bound args
now in es6 how do you use this in in my
actual implementation sample limitation
here of function.prototype.bind you can
see i'm importing bound function create
from internals
module system it's really nice um
and you can just call it like this so
you can see where at the bottom there's
the
it sort of translates up
and then this is just the current
function there'd actually be there'd be
more checks and stuff but this is just a
sort of cliff notes version of it
and the built-in libraries there's
all of these um so it's a it's a large
amount of code even though some of them
were like
just wrapping um exposed functions
from the host
environment it's still a significant
amount of code
and that's it
any questions
does this uh does this try to take
on detecting the host engine's
capabilities to try to optimize
what it's doing it doesn't try to
optimize um
it does it doesn't it wouldn't really be
any optimization to be done at that
level
um because i'm not going to store
like property descriptor information i
wouldn't want to store that in es5 for
example i wouldn't want to store that
as part of the object it would i guess
maybe i'm thinking mostly of like
the standard oh um
so the goal wasn't the goal was more to
like implement stuff in in
in javascript and see what it looked
like right so it wasn't
more about performance like i i could
have wrapped date but i did a full
implementation of the date spec just to
see what that would look like just you
know
it's a good reference even to look at it
um this sort of
answer that was another thing that i
thought was useful about it was
um spreading the spec is kind of
difficult it's very it's very
thick and it's it's it's describing like
what should happen
um based on you know backwards
compatibility in this and it's very
verbose
and it's a lot easier to actually read
like a javascript
version implementation of it and you're
like oh that makes a lot of sense when
the you know it's like
30 steps of like craziness you look at
the actual implementation it's just like
a lot more simple
so that's the goal there i didn't
implement regex because i didn't want to
i didn't want to implement that whole
thing but everything else i implemented
yeah it's definitely i mean there's
still some bugs and whatnot but it's
it's it's it's a little bit out of date
i think that's the biggest problem at
this point
because the spec has been moving so
quickly and it just
there's been so many iterations and so
many changes that there's some stuff
that isn't but i think most of the stuff
if you're trying to learn and you just
want to see how it works i think it's a
really good
good way to look at to test some code
out and get some feedback and
if you think about like how if you want
to use this feature for example or want
to give
that feedback to tc39 or es discuss
there's a few different ones um um
but like i think the most advanced at
this point is probably tracer
uh but still there's
there's some there's like a certain set
of features that
translates relatively easy there's a
smaller subset
that translates but it's hard like for
example generators and then there's a
bigger subset that doesn't translate at
all that you can't
um so if you were able to if you're
willing to limit yourself then yes
you can definitely i would look at
tracer um
there's a few others but i don't know of
any that are like have been worked on
recently
anyone else
how does this work like in the browser
does it just like
do you look for script tags or have a
funny type on them and then
oh no so if you want to execute it
doesn't like doesn't look at existing
code you have to be like
um you have to you know load the thing
and you get continuum you can do that
continue not create realm and then once
you have a realm you can do
realm.evaluate so you're basically a
valine code
and it's not doing any smart stuff about
like trying to find code
what's that if you want it you could
totally build that yeah you could it
would be yeah
um so generators i basically followed
the spec
um uh if you wanted to like transpile it
like a tracer does then you turn it into
a state machine but since i
actually am creating execution context
and i have the
i can pause code as it's executing i
actually take the execution context
and say when there's a yield i pop the
execution context
and that's saved on the function right
so the function has like current
execution context or whatever
and if you call that you know dot next
on that function
then it just pushes the execution
contacts back in the stack
the execution context has all of the
scope information all the local
variables in the current state
so we can just you can just do that and
that's how it's implemented
well it's it's like a um
a generator function in my
implementation is very similar to a
regular function there's almost no
difference
um it's just the fact that a generator
function can
pop it can be popped off so i mean i
guess
it's it's not really a state machine any
more than the regular function as a
state machine and that there's byte code
which you go from top to bottom
so you already have byte code in your
own runtime how much more work would it
be to like implement this on top of asmg
js um so the main me
i've thought about that that would be it
would be possible to actually optimize
it and make it do cool things at that
point
the main problem there is uh not the
byte code
it's the object representation since it
is somewhat meta-circular and that it
uses the object
i would have to represent that stuff in
a in a way that's
compatible it would be pointers and all
that stuff so that's a that's a big part
of the implementation i think the
complexity in
engines yeah you you would
exactly like that if you if you don't
use uh
host engine objects then you have to
implement the entire gc you can't skip
that part of the library using
continuum yeah can you give us an
opinion of
like the es6 stuff that you've used
oh yeah so i it was
after spending so much time working on
it and implementing the whole library in
es6
i just find it really frustrating and go
back to es5 um
there's a lot of people that don't like
classes but i really like that
i use them a lot for stuff because
especially in the library where
they specifically are classes so it fits
well
and it was kind of frustrating switching
back to having this sort of more verbose
where you have to like
implement your own like inherits kind of
thing um
and arrow functions were a big a big
awesome thing that i enjoyed now working
on the firefox devtools we actually can
i can use them all the time now so i
don't miss that so much but they're
really
useful to use and i think the biggest
thing
even though my implementation isn't
correct currently it's not the module
system implementation isn't
it doesn't follow spec because that's
changed so much the still the the basic
being able to implement some you know
use imports and exports
which is basically the same despite
whatever the resolver stuff and all
that's different
i think that's probably the biggest
change and i really really
liked using the module system it's just
it's a huge win
and it'll also fit in but i mean every
everybody's using modules
for different stuff so if we can just
get like
a trans source of source transformation
of like whatever require
or other stuff and be able to use i know
there's a library
out there i think that allows you to use
the esx module syntax and it will
convert it to whatever and i think that
that would that's pretty that's a pretty
big win
interoperability between the meta
language and the object language so that
your ex
code can interact with old es3
um is there any protection that you
offer
from one against the other so to a
certain extent you can do that um
uh i've experimented basically with
creating a wrapper
i don't think you if you if you're
talking about old es3 code you can't
because es in order to implement say
like
existing uh say host engine code that
that accesses properties on a vm
um you need to use like basically a
proxy or accessors at the very least
which means that you're sort of limited
to newer engines uh you know
spider monkey or v8 um
but the other way around works where say
like if you want to expose the dom
to continuum it's very you all you need
to do is create like custom
objects that the convert you know that
convert get to like
actually get properties on like the
wrapped object but going the other way
around is a lot more complicated if you
don't have proxies because you need to
implement the entire
uh meta object protocol to allow that to
happen
so there can be a lot of people out
there who've written a
javascript implementation in any degree
of
completeness yeah uh i know
three um
narcissus are you talking about
javascript and javascript or just
general
javascript javascript anything well
there's i mean you look at
are you talking about like one person
who's implemented all of it or talking
about like a team of people
i mean so like we look at every single
javascript engine most of them have
there's a lot of people and they have a
lot of
history to them so there's what
i don't know five or six major uh engine
implementations
um and i know of um
three javascript and javascript
implementations that are that vary
greatly but they're at least you know
implementations so i mean that's
i don't know maybe 10 total 12
something like that
anybody else
how well does it run continue on so
there is a bug i have been able to find
where there is an infinite loop from the
byte code and i cannot
whenever i try to write it's it's
something subtle
it could like it parses itself and it
creates all this stuff but as soon as i
try to run it
it just gets into an infinite loop in
the bytecode and i cannot figure out
what it is
it's it's somewhere in s prima it's some
switch statement craziness i don't know
i've tried for so long to get it to run
in itself and because i know it could if
i could just figure out what that bug
was
anybody else
i guess that's it thank you very much